bonsoir alexis merci d'être avec nous ce
soir la version finale du texte de
sortir de la crise sanitaire a donc été
votée au parlement quels en sont les
grands axes
oui le sénat a voté avec le refus du
groupe partis socialistes et des
communistes et les écologistes qui sont
abstenus mais ça y est le plan de sortie
de crise sanitaire est approuvée par le
parlement avec le pass sanitaire
évidemment qui est dans le lot avec un
régime de transition avec les lois
d'exception jusqu en octobre 2021 et la
vaccination pour tous qui est va
s'ouvrir le plus rapidement possible
puisque les chiffres continuent
d'augmenter sur le nombre de français
qui choisissent la vaccination
on est en train a évidemment d'organiser
cette sortie de crise via l'application
tout senti qu vite vous aurez des qr
codes également à scanner devant les
établissements tels que les bars les
restaurants et autres et puis il faudra
montrer patte blanche en europe avec se
passe à lithaire européen qui va se
mettre en place à au delà du passé inter
français pour pouvoir voyager et montrer
si vous êtes vacciné ou non porter d'u
coronavirus donc voilà c'est voter sans
vraiment de grands débats sur l'aspect
bioéthique du fait de maintenant
demander aux citoyens français et
d'autres pays européens
quel est leur statut par rapport à ce
virus c'est du jamais vu
et pourtant il n'ya pas eu de débat sur
la raison de cette mise en place
technologique de ce contrôle des
populations alors on comprend bien il ya
la pandémie certes mais est-ce que
c'était nécessaire
et pourquoi l'at-on faits sont réels
débats alexis un autre sujet qu'on a
abordé cette semaine même
hier et avant-hier l'académie de
médecine qui a préconisé cette semaine
une vaccination obligatoire
un scénario possible selon vous en dépit
des bons chiffres de la vaccination
oui alors les chiffres de la vaccination
qui avaient été annoncés par l'exécutif
s'était 20 millions de vaccinés à la mi
mai puis 30 millions à la mi juin on est
avec 4 millions de primo vacciner donc
une seule injection donc
l'exécutif va sans doute tenir ces
chiffres qui avaient été annoncés le
problème c'est qu'on a maintenant
autorités de santé effectivement qui
pousse gentiment vers un vaccin
obligatoire en disant attention on va
d'abord le rendre obligatoire à
certaines professions des professions de
contacter les soignants évidemment mais
tu peux pas les chauffeurs de taxi les
professeurs et d'autres qui ont du mal
effectivement à se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui on voit bien que la prise de
rendez vous pour les français qui
souhaitent se vacciner beaucoup plus
simple c'est beaucoup plus simple
d'avoir accès à la première dose mais ça
pose la question de cette daksi nation
obligatoire et certains d'ailleurs de ce
groupe de travail sont conscients que le
rendre la vaccination obligatoire
pourrait provoquer un effet inverse avec
une levée de boucliers et rendre plus
compliquée la vaccination donc on est
petit à petit on continue en fait ces
stratégies du nudge c'est à dire qu'on
s'est à une stratégie de 2,2
comportementale qui pousse les gens à
adopter un comportement sans avoir
l'impression d'être contraints c'est
l'idée du passé ni terre évidemment
c'est une idée ses phrases qu'on a
entendu de dire si certains choisissent
de ne pas se faire vacciner ils auront
la vie beaucoup plus compliqué dans la
société qu'on leur propose donc
évidemment beaucoup de français vont se
dire moi j'ai pas envie d'être embêté
pour prendre l'avion pour aller au
restaurant pour faire ce que je veux
faire en fait donc je vais me faire
vacciner même si ce n'est pas
obligatoire le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on entend des gens comme
alain fischer qui est le monsieur vaccin
du gouvernement dira que pour atteindre
l' immunité de groupe c'est à dire le
moment où on aura suffisamment de gens
qui ont des anticorps face au virus
il faudrait peut-être vacciner les
enfants dès 12 ans et l'autorité de
santé européennes est en train bien sûr
de regarder si ces vaccins fonctionne
c'est déjà le cas dans d'autres pays
et bien sûr la france suivrait en
faisant et pourquoi pas vacciner les
enfants le problème qui se pose c'est
pourquoi vacciner des enfants qu'ils ne
risquent pas grand chose du coronavirus
si ce n'est effectivement qu'ils sont
porteurs et qu'ils peuvent continuer la
propagation de la pandémie est là il ya
une vraie question à la fois sur le
consentement de mineur sur la place des
parents dans ce choix vaccinale et puis
sur le retour de ces technologies arn
qui sont en fait des technologies de
nouvelles et dont on ne sait pas ce
qu'elles peuvent faire dans les années
qui viennent même si les laboratoires
aujourd'hui nous et ce qu'elles sont
absolument sûrs et qu'elles sont
efficaces donc on est en train de créer
en fait de nouveaux problèmes sur cette
vaccination alors même qu'on arrive à
vacciner suffisamment d'adultes pour
atteindre potentiellement limité de
groupe
dernière question quand on commente
l'actualité politique emmanuel macron
préparé un tour de france à quoi cela
va-t-il ressembler et pourquoi ce timing
alors emmanuel macron nous parle encore
une fois d'une grande concertation d'un
tour de france où il va prendre son
bâton de pèlerin aller voir des
entreprises faire des visites surprises
un peu dans les différentes régions
françaises
appelons un chat un chat mails macron
entre en campagne
il est est en train de faire une
campagne électorale il va aller au
contact des populations des différents
territoires sans doute avec des maires
qui sont amies des régions qui sont à
plus tôt république en marche
il est en train de faire campagne avec
cette stature qui est celle du président
de la république mais ils macky sall
comme d'habitude comme il a l'habitude
de le faire
sous des allures de grande concertation
on connaît les grandes concertations des
malades mâcon il y a eu le grand débat
lors des gilet jaune ça s'est soldé par
des monologues d'emmanuel macron seul au
milieu de foule silencieuse où il
prenait la parole pour expliquer qu'il
était le meilleur et que sa politique
était formidable il est en train de
refaire exactement la même chose je
crois que on a suffisamment souper des
grandes concertations de la république
en marche
d'ailleurs ce parti rappelez vous à
commencer par une grande concertation ce
qui s'appelle la grande marche ou les
référents république en marche à frapper
aux portes des français pour demander ce
qu'il souhaitait faire ce qu'il
souhaitait voir changer dans la
politique française est bien
cinq ans après on en est au même point
avec emmanuel macron il est toujours à
nous vendre la même recette marketing de
la grande concertation alors qu'il est
en fait question d'une mise en scène de
sa personne et de défense de son bilan
simplement par sa parole qui va être
relayée évidemment par tous les médias
puisqu'il est président de la république
mais c'est une campagne politique est en
train de se jouer à la fois avec les
régionales mais surtout avec 2022 en
ligne
merci alexis